how's gum Brea's this beautiful guess
where I am I'm in Tokyo it's pretty
awesome
it's 6:30 I'm really jet-lagged so I
decided to go for a run but I'm really
lost also I found this and room it
reminds me of tub girl you know that
photo if you if you know tub girl you
know what I'm talking about when I do
this Jesus Christ all right I'm gonna
keep going
I'll explain more while we're here
actually we're just here on holiday but
we're here with some friends and I
wanted to vlog a little bit and it's the
first time I've log outside without
Marty and it's super awkward I'm gonna
stop now let's go
I don't know what's going on this is
super weird
some kind of cult should I join in
this kid I like you I'm feel part of
their culture
all right it's now I forgot my watch I
don't know what type of disease Mars is
here and then we're just having
breakfast and we're gonna go to the key
but we happen which is typical tourist
first thing today yeah this is it guys
this is the place to be
I'm having a lot of fun
we're in guys we're in which one should
be playing oh my god Marcel found good
it's out
it's gonna be mean soon enough
oh my god such a loser I just want this
pillow
come on hello it didn't Eve you're safe
Marsha don't worry I'm gonna get this
one and their powers combined and they
become a junk kids look at this what is
this that looks great what are you
talking about Phoenix I don't want you
to think you've wasted your money but
you've wasted your money this is a time
Chuck Manson do you want to get that one
why are you doing this to me guys I
don't know what happened to Pikachu
we in right side again become parents
finally everybody could use Sasuke he
likes rice I needs a whole bowl Oh eat
too much
we gotta keep hitting it by accident all
right now we're in some kind of park
thing and I just got recognized hey
how's it going
chicken ha ha so anyway these are the
losers that we're going with I'm really
jet lag it's really it's only like 3
p.m. but I'm tired I don't know what
we're doing next but I hope it's
something with a lot of explosions
look there's fishes that one knows just
like your Marcia welcome oh and your
what's up I'm eating for free Nick oh
catfishing
can't believe that they let you eat cats
in Japan I'm really excited
I hope they taste good look at this view
guys I don't want to buy any drugs
I'm very weirded out by this place I
feel like I'm in a Taylor Swift concert
guys running in the high life I'm Sookie
are you allowed to send them Hey
like now that was spectacular
frigging done taping Jeff's on first
please announce you're not named the
camera who I Felix Swedish boy tries
Japanese candy
this is today's nail I've kept it on
everyone else bailed on the nail I'm
taking over the vlog everyone else
bailed and I'm very pissed off about it
nail transition oh actually that's it
okay I got it which this okay uh I'll
just pretend you've handed this to me
thanks Felix Thank You PJ now we're
going to unbox this item it's an old man
and you get a different one each time so
I'm very excited to see who we're gonna
get we got the laying one week it's
super rare he's so nice
great unboxing no pigeon don't do it I
have all the power down do I have all
the time oh I kill me Oh what's wrong
Japan trip are you alright good morning
and I figured I'd end this vlog the same
way I started it but yeah I don't I
didn't really want to vlog more than one
day because I just want to not worry
about uploading videos and editing while
I'm here so that's okay
I hope one-one blog is enough and I hope
it was enjoyable if it was let me know
and maybe I'll do more of these so leave
a like if you enjoyed and I'm gonna try
and find my way back home and edit this
vlog so that's it for me for now and as
always I can't tell you what happened
but I can show you my clothes
right